bonjour et bienvenue pour cette science
aujourd'hui consacré aux extractions
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bah c'est une
météorite est pourquoi tout de suite une
météorite pourquoi quand on part
d'extinction menace tout le monde pense
immédiatement aux dinosaures et aux
météorites pas c'est peut-être tout
simplement que les gens on a convaincu
qu'une extinction c'est forcément une
catastrophe gigantesque vient d'un même
qu'on leur dit croire à fond
pourtant une grande conséquence comme
une extinction de masse n'a pas
forcément pour origine une grande cause
connaissez-vous l'effet papillon mieux
connu sous l'adage veut dire qu séquence
il est souvent résumée par l'affirmation
suivante le battement d'aile d'un
papillon au japon peut déclencher un
ouragan aux états-unis - ça sent bon la
philosophie orientale de bistrot tout ça
en fait ça même l'air de la barre aucun
sens mais on va vous expliquer l'effet
papillon est un effet prédit par une
théorie mathématique appelé cette
branche des mathématiques nous apprend
entre autre chose qu'un phénomène
complexe aussi connu soit il restera
imprévisible même si on n'en comprend
tous ces mécanismes
prenons par exemple la météo les
météorologistes connaissent tous les
facteurs qui influencent la météo
pression atmosphérique relief
température vents et marées et pourtant
bah il va faire beau pu viser la météo
ce tron tout le temps mais pourquoi et
m'a simplement parce que les conditions
météorologiques ne se résume pas à la
seule somme des facteurs qui
l'influencent c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué que ça ces nombreux facteurs
interagissent entre eux de façon
imprévisible voire aléatoire et d'autres
facteurs que l'on considère comme
visiblement négligeable tels que le
battement d'aile d'un papillon par
exemple peuvent avoir de très grandes
conséquences sur la météo de demain
il en résulte la fameuse la
prévisibilité dans le système complexe
bref le climat est imprévisible car il
est plus compliqué à comprendre que la
somme des facteurs qui le composent et
un écosystème c'est pareil de l'air de
manger par des herbivores manger par des
carnivores ça c'est la version lite
façon walt disney c'est la pointure
fillette mais en réalité c est
infiniment plus compliqué que ça sans
parler aussi des variations du climat
des barrières géographiques des espèces
parasie de l'accès aux ressources et de
la façon dont les espèces interagissent
voici à tout petit exemple pour vous
montrer à quel point ça peut être
compliqué certaines bactéries qui sont
des parasites pour les plantes agissent
comme agent de nucléation et aide à la
formation de nuages
c'est l'image leur permettent ensuite de
se disperser d'une forêt à l'autre grâce
à la pluie et c'est ainsi qu'elle
infecte d'autres plantes et autant vous
dire qu'il est presque impossible
d'imaginer la totalité des conséquences
qu'un tel mode de vie a pu avoir sur les
climats du passé et encore moins seule
qu'il aura pour les climats du futur un
écosystème c'est infiniment compliqué
donc infiniment imprévisible il peut
aller très bien un moment et un autre
plus le système peut s'effondrer et
alors c'est le crash
l'extinction de masse regarder la courbe
de gravité des extinctions de masse en
fonction du temps nous sommes d'ici et
le big d'extinction correspondant à la
fin du règne des dinosaures se trouve la
remarquer l'existence de cinq ou six
autres piques d'extinction et ensuite
admirer le nombre autrement plus grand
de tous les autres petits pics
correspondant à des extinctions plus
mineures ces graphiques nous apprend que
l'impact des
d'action sur la biodiversité est
inversement proportionnelle à la
fréquence à laquelle les extinctions ont
lieu en d'autres termes que les
extinctions areva d'autant moins souvent
qu'elles seront faciles au contraire des
tas de petites extinction auront lieu
très souvent d'où la parente rythmicité
des extinctions de masse mais alors
c'est quand même pas une météorite
quelques et chacune de ces extinctions
safri gagne beaucoup de météorites en
créant une simulation d'écosystèmes sur
ordinateur des chercheurs ont réussi à
déterminer que balancer météorite sur
les animaux virtuels déclenché
effectivement une extinction de masse on
va ça c'est une surprise
jusque là rien d'anormal vous prenez une
météorite sur le coin de la mouille
s'affaiblit bien bas mais ensuite les
chercheurs ont rajouté un élément à
leurs simulations l'évolution des
espèces désormais des espèces virtuel
engagés dans la course pour leur
maintien ne sont plus immuable mais
hommes outre régulièrement et alors
surprise il se produit spontanément les
mêmes extinction de masse des crashs du
système écologique surviennent à
intervalles réguliers sans raison
catastrophique les espèces s'éteignent
d'elle-même
plus besoin de météorites la conclusion
de cette expérience c'est que
l'évolution en elle même est une cause
d'extinction régulière des espèces elle
maintient l'équilibré entre les espèces
mais c'est un équilibre tendue au bord
du ko par le jeu de la sélection
naturelle les espèces entrent et sortent
perpétuellement sur la scène évolutive
elles apparaissent se font concurrence
puis elle évolue ou disparaissent sans
cesse la scène évolutive se renouvelle
ainsi indéfiniment si une espèce entre
retard dans cette course
elle disparaît qui va à la chasse perd
sa place dit le proverbe
cela pourrait s'arrêter là ou bien les
espèces qui dépendent est de cette
espèce là parasites bactéries
intestinales prédateurs et proies
disparaissent avec elle et ensuite les
espèces dont la survie dépend des de ces
espèces la meure à leur tour et ainsi de
suite comme un jeu de dominos et alors
c'est la catastrophe c'est tout le
système qui peut s'effondrer c'est
l'extinction de masse tout ça pour une
seule espèce comme le battement d'aile
d'un papillon
vous voyez pas besoin de grandes
catastrophes pour faire de grandes
extinctions les extinctions de masse
sont une conséquence inévitable de
l'évolution une espèce mute à paris où
disparaît et les conséquences peuvent
être négligeable ou monumentales
pas encore convaincu alors essayez de
vous représenter à quel point
l'apparition d'une seule espèce homo
sapiens en l'occurrence a pu totalement
changé la face du monde est bouleversé
la quasi-totalité des éco systèmes
globaux en à peine cent mille ans le
temps d'un battement d'aile de papillon
à l'échelle des temps géologiques
pour en savoir plus sur ces sujets nous
vous recommandons la lecture de
simplicité profonde de john grimett
merci à tous
c'est ça a été rude et cargo